recently real-life lore Wendover
productions and i had the opportunity to
travel to the northernmost city in north
america Barrow Alaska while there is
plenty of fascinating information
regarding this Arctic frontier town this
video is going to take a slightly more
personal approach instead of facts and
figures I'm going to read an excerpt
from the journal I kept in Barrow and
share some first impressions
[Music]
Barrow Alaska is beautiful perhaps not
in the traditional sense as aside from a
handful of respectable hotels and
government buildings the city could only
be described as fruity faded and
utilitarian but for all its dust and mud
and near total lack of creature comforts
Barrow manages to make you smile not
without a scarf around your face of
course as your lips are liable to crack
from the cold should you attempt it
Barrow is a town utterly without
pretense
it makes no excuses for its rugged
appearance nor would you expect it to as
everyone in town has more important
things to do so while it is true that
the town is unapologetically Spartan for
it to be any other way would seem
disingenuous you wouldn't expect an
opera house or a Botanical Garden or any
other such frivolities from a frontier
town and you won't find them here but
what you do get is something much more
special this frozen town of 5,000 people
sits on the very edge of the Arctic
Ocean
and expanse largely covered in thick sea
ice and drifts of snow trudging across
the dirty gray stretch of sand along the
ocean in layers upon layers of winter
clothing and looking out over the
endless expanse of life makes you
realize how uniquely unsuited humans are
to such an environment the fact that
polar bears are known to wander along
the icy coast just a stone's throw from
the beach certainly adds to that feeling
of being in a position of inferiority as
you leave the shoreline and walk along
the muddy roads of Barrow you can begin
to piece together a ramshackle history
of the stubborn outpost cars and trucks
in varying stages of decay litter the
outskirts and snowdrifts of town here a
work truck half buried in snow its
windows shattered and door hanging
monthly from its engines there a ruined
old car paint nearly stripped there and
sunk into the bumpers and thick
lud an entire lineage of automobiles
stretching back to the beginning of
barrow itself which coughed their last
and were left to crumble where they
stood defeated by conditions too
unforgiving for all but the most robust
utility vehicles as I sit writing this
the clock inches towards midnight and
yet outside the window the town remains
bathed in a dull blue grey light the
trucks pass less frequently and the
goals have mostly settled for the night
but the Sun refuses to relinquish its
grip on the day during this time of year
week after week of unforgiving sunlight
makes blackout shades a necessity with
which thankfully our hotel is equipped
this harsh day-to-day reality is what
makes Barrow so beautiful in its own
special way the juxtaposition that lime
drawn in the sand between man and nature
a place where for all our ingenuity
nature still gets the best of us it's
not a place I'd like to stay it's not a
place I'll likely visit again but it's
certainly not a place I'll ever forget I
[Music]
know this video is very different from
what you're used to seeing on this
channel so be sure to let me know what
you think in the comments should we go
on more adventures like this and make
more in depth videos share your opinion
make sure to stay tuned for videos from
real-life lower and window for
productions on the subject of Barrow
Alaska if you enjoyed this video you can
subscribe by clicking here
you can watch my previous video by
clicking here or watch all my videos by
clicking here and finally come check out
the new combined real life lore and
second thought Instagram where we share
pictures of our adventures and daily
life thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video